white house considering cash payments to
central americans
to stem migration i love that headline
because the headline makes no sense you
should actually
you should actually just say white house
considering considers
giving cash to illegal immigrants which
will do nothing and they'll come anyway
and then it'll cost even more money
that's a better headline here's his new
york post reports
they say the potential cash cash
transfer program would be targeted at
residents of guatemala honduras and el
salvador
which counts for the overwhelming
majority of migrants illegally crossing
the border
roberta jacobson the white house
southern border coordinator told the
outlet
we're looking at all of the productive
options to address both the economic
reasons
people may be migrating as well as the
protection and security reasons
jacobson told the outlet in an interview
in march nearly 170
000 migrants were picked up by u.s
border patrol agents at the southern
border
a 70 increase from february
all right you get the gist of the story
you ready for the big hammer drop
who who was it who said that they were
planning on doing this why
it was uh well let me treat it that
this is roberta jacobson the white
house's southern border coordinator
telling the new york post we're looking
at all of the productive options to
address both the economic reasons and
she's gone oh white house border
coordinator roberta jacobson resigns
as biden struggles to contain the
historic surge
in in migrants it's amazing because
it looks like this story about her
resignation came before
the new york post was able to publish
the story where she said we're just
gonna pay these people
look america's awesome everybody wants
to be here i get it
i would love everyone to find the
american dream you got to do it the
legal
the legal way the law is set up not
because we hate people
but it's because we want to make sure
people don't wander through the desert
and die we want to make sure human
traffickers aren't trafficking children
we want to make sure that guy with that
little girl
is actually related to that little girl
and you can't do it when people just
pour across the border
so this is this is one of the most
insane things i've ever heard i don't
know what you guys think i think most
people just their jaws just dropped once
like the us will give money
to these people to make them not come
they're gonna come anyway
it sounds like they're considering
bribing foreign nationals to not commit
a crime
with our own tax money it's insane to me
the consideration is absolutely insanity
to me so you're
you're more the libertarian but i think
would you say little l or big l
small small l it's look it's it's guilt
money uh
we know what this it's guilt money first
and foremost
uh my point of view is that the the best
immigrant wall of all is a lack of
economic growth can we
let's not forget that from 2009 to 2014
more people left the united states and
crossed back over the southern border
than came
in as long as the u.s is awesome
people are going to come here to me
that is a market phenomenon that they're
trying to solve with central planning is
it any surprise when you solve something
with central planning that you have a
crisis
what i would give if both sides
acknowledge
that there's a need for workers and so
let's
let's legalize work in some way it's
never going to happen because both sides
want to politicize this and they will
continue to do this this will never be
solved
it's like the people who say let's have
a flat or sales tax
yeah good luck it's never going to
happen it's not in the in the incentive
of congress to simplify
the tax code they will never solve this
with free markets
but i guess one of the challenges is
different sectors require workers you
know not every single sector can have
the same kind of labor done
so a lot of the people who'd be coming
from central america they're not going
to be
computer programmers or you know solar
panel engineers
they're probably going to be low-skilled
workers or laborers is that a fair
assessment
it's a fair assessment in some way but
what if
we legalized work what if we said we're
not going to discriminate
based on on your coming from somewhere
else to some degree people
have to do low value work once they're
here because that's the
the easiest way to not be discovered how
many cuban immigrants going back to the
1960s came here
they were educated but were busboys once
they were in the united states
so once you legalize things you'd get a
greater disbursement of workers i think
you'd also get a lot more talented
workers to come here because
we know this well if you're a foreign
talent and come here to school
you can go to school here but you can't
necessarily stay here i'll tell you this
that sounds like a way better solution
than just giving them money and hoping
they don't come
because i'm pretty sure if they give if
we give them money they're gonna come
anyway
i i don't think giving someone cash
there's no contract there what is that
yeah well the coyotes will see that
money and say okay here's the money that
will help you get across the border i
think it you can't
look north korea is a police state
but people still come in and out of
north korea
we think in a free country like this
that we can keep them out and it's
always
struck me as odd that people on my side
say well
we want limited government but we also
want strict border enforcement
sorry the two contradict you cannot have
a very strong border enforcement with
guns and also have limited government so
to me it's always been make a choice and
i would prefer
that we'll we have a market solution but
that is my the idealist in me talking
but i i don't i don't think
uh i don't think you necessarily
disagree with many of the conservatives
or many even
even pro-borders and libertarians i
think everybody agrees if we could find
places for these people through a legal
process
we could keep track we could make sure
people are succeeding well that's great
the problem is they're wandering through
the desert they're coming with coyotes
and smugglers
kids are dying and so it's basically
chaos
right i think it was donald trump who
said something the fact of you know have
everybody come everybody but they got to
do it legally
that's kind of the idea maybe it is but
if they had the same rules that when our
ancestors got here and they probably all
got here at different times
most of us couldn't be here today if the
rules that prevailed today prevailed
50 years ago 100 years ago 200 years ago
most of us wouldn't be here
and so sure i would love legal too but
when you make the legality of it so
limited is it any surprise that you get
the most desperate people crossing
uh crossing through the desert and
everything if you had a legal process
again a market-driven process when you
don't have central planning i think what
you'd find is you'd have people coming
the normal way
because there'd be an incentive to come
the normal way and you could have
fewer guns at the border because if you
say we legalize the work process there's
demand for human capital here
the minute someone steps into the united
states they become exponentially
productive by virtue of being in this
country
if you legalize that they're not going
to sneak over at which point you can
have fewer government agents
targeting the very few who don't
announce themselves in the first place
but do you think uh many of these
workers displace
entry-level workers american citizens
who are trying to enter the workforce
no so one of one of the things and good
point
well we'll i'll follow up but i want you
to go more in depth but i want to make
one point because one of the things
we've actually heard a lot millennials
say that around 2008 when they're
getting out of school and they're
entering the workforce the economy
collapsed
all of a sudden now gen xers are
occupying these lower skilled jobs and
they can't find work
i experienced this to a certain degree i
was trying to get a job as a dishwasher
because i was desperate
and i come in and there's some you know
i'm in my uh late teens or i'm 20 or 21
years old
and there's a guy who's in his 30s in a
suit with a briefcase trying to be a
dishwasher for minimum wage
i couldn't get the job it was impossible
so i ended up playing guitar in a subway
now we're hearing from the you know gen
z where they're saying
you've got all the millennials now
finally starting to you know come into
these positions and take these jobs and
we entered this
this broken system in shambles with an
economic crisis in our youth
and now an economic crisis the pandemic
so you have a lot of young people who
have repeatedly seen some kind of
struggle in terms of getting work
now you have an argument for many people
of relaxing the borders allowing more
labor to come in to compete with people
who have already had
a hard go of it um it's a fair argument
but i don't think we can have it both
ways in this argument we can't say
they're coming in and taking the jobs
that no one else wants to do at the same
time saying they're
taking jobs from college-educated
millennials but i'm not saying that i'm
saying i tried to be a dishwasher and i
couldn't because
the work was displaced i mean dishwasher
i wouldn't say it's a job no one wants
to do
you know donald trump during his
presidency there was a raid on several
meat processing plants
in north carolina maybe mississippi and
arkansas maybe a couple states
and i think they deported about 700
people and those jobs immediately got
filled at a higher wage to american
citizens
so there were several people who were
interviewed there was you know this one
one dude said
they asked him why are you coming to
this job fair and he goes it pays better
than mcdonald's
and so these people came into these jobs
and then that opens up jobs in fast food
for
16 year olds who are entering the job
market who need to work
um should we abolish computers should we
abolish
the mobile phone should we abolish wi-fi
should we abolish your website because i
guarantee everything that i just said
has displaced all
sorts of people now my answer to that
would be that's called progress
because the world before that was a much
more brutal
cruel world for people look we could
abolish
the the tractor the car and the airplane
right now and we'd all have
jobs we would be desperately poor but we
would all have jobs and so
this notion that people somehow drive
away
jobs ignores that where are jobs the
scarcest right now or
are they are they just abundant and
flint because no one's going there or
are they more abundant in san jose
where there are lots of people going
well las vegas there's lots of work
and it's lots of people moving from
places where there's not it's
work people don't drive away work what
drives away work is a lack of investment
and so what attracts investment talent
so where the talented people go there's
always going to be abundant jobs and so
i think it's a mistake to look at work
as a finite supply it's rarely that
i would add too i think one of the
biggest problems we have in this country
is
cultural a lot of the young people that
i i reference
because you know we hear from young
people saying i wish i could work but i
can't you know the economy the
immigration well it's also true a lot of
these younger people are really entitled
and they're told by their parents you
should be an astronaut instead of a
plumber
plumber is an extremely important job i
gotta say astronauts are incredibly
important
in a certain sense that you know what
elon musk is doing with spacex
is going to advance human human human
experience and human text not technology
in amazing ways
but i'll tell you this a plumber is more
needed
we we you need a plumber day today yeah
day to day um
you need substantially more plumbers and
electricians and carpenters than you
need
astronauts but they're all they're
important it's just you know we got
young people who are told
why should i do a trade why should i do
why should i figure out how to build
something
they want to be a rock star they want to
be a youtuber well even like a
successful youtuber needs to understand
tech i mean you would not be successful
if you didn't understand cameras
microphones
you know programming those are all these
are trade trades being able to work
cameras that's a trade
like a technology trade you know in the
industry you'd be like uh
in the union you know as a as a as a
tech
i think i think you bring up a good
point i've i've heard similar points
made
particularly from libertarians and i
think one of the big issues
that i would agree with we need people
to just work
you don't need to work for someone else
you can work you can literally wake up
in the morning and be like
i found a piece of dirt on the ground
and i'm going to shape it into a little
man and sell it to somebody i think
the value sell the value that work is
important but i think the job economy
is part of the ponzi scheme of the
federal reserve kind of their ethos is
i want everyone working i want everyone
to have a job
i want this guy to dig a hole and then i
want this guy to go fill the hole back
up and well yeah we'll pay them both
with
our money so they'll keep borrowing our
money at interest so that they'll keep
paying these people to be busy
and then they'll keep owing us interest
and then as long as they're busy they're
not going to realize that we're
a parasite on the system that we're
sucking this this interest off the top
and we're headed towards automation
where we don't need to dig the holes
we're building machines to do that
so as the age of automation dawns the
job
economy is going to is going to fade
away
but in a beautiful way let's be clear
that automation and robots
are the greatest friend to the worker
that the world has ever known
and nothing else comes close let's not
forget that when
when you were born 175 years ago in the
rich u.s
your choices were binary in life you'll
either be a farmer
or something else related to farming
what changed that tractor backhoe
fertilizer the biggest robotic job
destroyers in the history of the world
did they put us into breadlines no they
freed people to become
astronauts to create cars to create
computers become math teachers
robots are going to take all that's
awful out of work out of it
all the drudgery out of it and allow
specialization on a level that's going
to lift people
that for hundreds of years we might have
thought stupid who suddenly get to do
something that uniquely elevates their
intelligence
work is endless it's the kind of work
that is not endless in a dynamic society
and that's true
and the the big problem we then face is
cultural stagnation
people who want to be youtubers or
bloggers for buzzfeed instead of people
who want to
explore and develop the new technology
so i
i read i was reading about the um you
know ancient rome and greece the
mediterranean
and how the great philosophers came
about and how math started to emerge
and it was because humans all of a
sudden find themselves
in this very beautiful climate it's
always warm there's fruit
there's abundance and so a lot of free
time on their hands
some people laid about and were lazy and
gluttonous and pretty bad
and others found something to occupy
their time
i think one of the problems we have is
that as a lot of people when they when
they enter
this position where they lose their job
they complain to the government about it
what are you going to do you have people
on the left where they'll say something
like the government should just give me
money
it's like well you're not doing anything
anyway sure i guess
but then you have on the right people
saying we should regulate the industries
maybe bring these companies back a lot
of what trump was doing
i actually would agree more with you
know creating incentives for companies
to exist here
but outside of all of that i think the
big problem we have is absolutely
cultural stagnation
movies are just remakes reboots
adaptations
take an old comic make a new version of
it we need new things
we need people to be pioneers we need
people to say i'm going to move to the
middle of nowhere and wyoming and build
a city
just there's so much work to be done you
just got to do it
i guess the the main issue though is
people want to be rich you're not going
to be rich
being a guy who starts a new city you
know you know you might be you might
have purpose
maybe and like yeah maybe like you were
saying 100 years ago you
we were all poor when we were 200 years
ago we were all poor compared today
you're rich
like if you're sitting in your house and
you have the heater running and you have
running water that's clean and access to
the internet you're rich
you don't need billions and trillions to
be rich these days so you just
you know as long as the the automation
enables the technology to be awesome
you're rich
you did it and it does look
ibm comes out with the first mainframe
computer in the 1960s
intensely slow filled a room larger than
this if you wanted to own it was going
to cost you well over a million dollars
nowadays i have a super computer that
fits in my pocket that i got for a few
hundred dollars that is
exponentially faster and more capable
right here our i can go on amazon
i've we've got alexa at home and i've
got access
to billions worth of music every single
day
for 4.99 a month we are billionaires in
so many ways today
because of the profit motive and what's
scary is to think in the future what
we're going
you you are producing a television show
with three people
here and then a guest like me
that how many however many years ago how
much would it have cost to produce this
and you're doing this
from a house in rural maryland yeah
it's staggering what's what's being
created
at microscopic levels of cost and so
when people are pessimistic and when
they tell you they can't get a job no no
no no
it's tim says no you're not happy with
the jobs available that you can get
it's kind of like there are years ago i
wrote an op-ed they
jennifer aniston is unmarried
by choice not because she couldn't get
married there are hundreds of millions
of men who would give anything to be
married to jennifer aniston
what's available she doesn't think is
worthy
what's available in the us for workers
is not living up to the standards
to what you elude entitled kids well so
this is uh
there is a challenge here though i often
talk about how here in the u.s we're all
fairly rich especially when you look at
other countries and the
you know per capita gdp yeah the average
american working at mcdonald's
substantially wealthier than the middle
class brazilian
i think their gdp a few years ago was
like 8 dollars a year
so even if you're working at mcdonald's
for only 40 hours a week you're doing
better
the issue is we have certain standards
and costs of living
rent might be a certain rate so while
there are some people who are you know
you can point out we've got alexa we've
got all this great technology
you can get anything you want basically
shipped to your house i got japanese
soda
sent here japanese it's crazy it's a
little marble and you slam it and then
actually it's great and uh it comes here
to the middle of nowhere
however we have access to a lot of these
things
but rent is still really high so you
can't
be you know you can't just go and work
that easily
you know i'll mention we need pioneers
right go and start a city but you need
some level of capital to do it and if
you lose your job because your factory
goes to mexico or china
you can't pay your rent or your mortgage
anymore and if you decide okay well then
i'll just flip burgers
you still can't just pay your mortgage
anymore it's you're not gonna be able to
afford rent so
there's work to be done but an
individual can't just snap their fingers
and decide to start working on something
and cover their costs thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you